So this is everything you need to know
about extending regular notifications
for a great experience on Android Wear.
Your application remains
basically the same as before, but
we used Werable extensions to add more
detail that is useful on Android Wear.
The Android Wear software takes
care of all the hard parts such as,
showing the user interface and
handling speech recognition.
Another thing to know,
is that these kinds of extensions
are quite common in Android.
Similar concepts are used to handle
messaging with Android Auto.
So, you'll be able to use similar
techniques to extend your software
to many different platforms.